♪ ♪
- Okay, uh, in this commercial,
you guys are gonna
be trying to
come into this club to dance,
and this guy here is gonna say,
"Hey, why don't we dance
together?"
And you all...will think
it's a great idea, okay?
Is that good? Cool?
- Yeah, sounds good to me.
- Yeah, great.
- Let's shoot one, huh?
It's gonna be fun.
- All right, and...action.
- Hey, kids, let's party
together.
[together]
Yeah.
- I for sure want to party with
this guy.
- Well, then, all right.
- And...cut.
- Good job. Awesome.
That was really, really good.
- Sam.
- Great job, guys.
- Yeah, uh-huh.
- What is that?
- Oh, here come some notes.
Flying in notes.
This is all part of it.
It's fun.
- [whispering indistinctly]
- Yeah, okay, great job on that
last one, guys.
I'll tell you what, we've got
to do it one more time,
because I had a little sound
issue.
The boom was in the shot.
You could see it.
- Dang it, Tommy.
- Tommy, come on.
So let's do it one more time,
and just so we have it,
all right, Lea, we can do it
again, but this time,
maybe it would be fun
if you said
they can't come in and dance in
the club, so, you know,
so we have it like we had
in the original script.
- Right, but my only thing is,
why wouldn't they
want him to dance?
Like, they kind of see him as,
like, a friend
and as, like,
a guy they look up to.
He's also a peer.
- Yeah, maybe--I just think
so that we had it at least
both ways so we could...
- I'm not into the other way.
- Yeah, okay.
- I've--I've seen it.
I've seen that done before.
- Uh...
- Do you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- Ah...let's just do it
the same way again then.
- Thanks. Thanks, Sam.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
Same again, guys.
- And...ugh...
and action.
[upbeat funky music]
- Hey, kids, you want to party
together?
[together]
Yeah.
- Yes.
- I for sure want to
party with this guy.
- All right.
Give me some skin.
- And cut.
- Sam.
- Yeah, no, I know.
- Come on.
What's--what's...
What's going on here?
Is it just me?
[both mumbling indistinctly]
- That was good for me,
but one thing is,
the kid who's supposed to say,
"I for sure want to
party with him,"
he's, like, kind of squinting
his eyes.
It's, like, I don't
really believe him.
- Yeah, no shit, 'cause why
would he say that?
- This is supposed to be
a commercial
for a club where teens can go
and have a cool,
safe space to hang out.
And now it's a commercial
where a bunch of cool teens
want to hang out with...
an adult,
who legally wouldn't be allowed
in the club in the first place.
- Yeah, that's
the whole point, though.
He doesn't go into the club.
They just want him to.
- Why would they want to
party with a weird old man?
- Who's a weird old man?
- Honey.
- Me?
How am I old or weird?
- Well, a fedora don't work--
- Strongly disagree.
- That jacket--
- Everybody shut up.
Watch this.
Hey, kids, if this wasn't
a commercial,
this was real life, and I came
up to you in a teen club,
would you dance with me?
- Tim, no.
- Shh, watch, shh.
Would you dance with me?
Stacy, Stacy, would you dance
with me?
Betsy, dancing?
Hugo, what do you say, bro-bro,
you dancing?
Miranda, if this wasn't
a commercial,
this was real life,
and we're at a teen dance,
Miranda,
would you dance with me?
- Okay, enough.
Either he goes
or you're both fired.
- You know what?
I think you're only left with
one option, Andrea.
- Come on down to Boom teen
nightclub,
the premier teen club in metro
Detroit.
- Can we party with you,
Mr. Groove?
- Pfft, I wish, because that
is one cool club.
But it's just for teens.
[together]
Aww.
- Hey, don't be so sad, teens.
You're gonna have a great time.
- I wish Mr. Groove was a teen.
- Hmm, let me see
what I can do.
[together]
Yeah!
- Come to Boom, metro
Detroit's premier teen club.
- Tell 'em Mr. Groove sent ya.
- That was the commercial
that led to the shutdown
of Boom teen nightclub
earlier today,
where a swarm of middle-age men
were arrested
for posing as teens attempting
to gain entry.
When asked what they were
doing,
the men said,
"Mr. Groove sent us."
Between you and me, it seems
like that commercial
was telling old me how to
sneak into a teen club.
- I think we should have
a policy where we're not in